this Hollywood babble-on with your hosts
Kevin Smith and Ralph Garman the
greatest drunk story I've ever heard in
chiapas history he was on a cruise ship
in Miami
January 12th at leaves Miami it's going
to Jamaica he's performing on there and
while he's on the ship he runs into a
trace adkins impersonator Trace Adkins
the country star runs into a trace
adkins impersonator
can we show a picture of the two of them
together this is apparently is from the
trip there that's that that's the real
Trace Adkins and the impersonator Trace
Adkins starts talking to this guy and
then Trace Adkins in person here fake
trick and trace Haskins fake Trace
Adkins it's not easy to say he starts
doing karaoke in the bar to trace adkins
song in front of Trace Adkins the parent
starts talking some [ __ ] so newly drunk
Trace Adkins starts beating the [ __ ] out
of impersonator transactions there's a
fight going on between real Trace Adkins
and fake Trace Adkins it is the physical
personification of self-loathing the
drunken self-hatred he's beating himself
up in a bar on a cruise ship it's like
when Superman fought himself
in the junkyard the boat docks in
Jamaica that kids hightails it out of
there
we don't know we have to run some DNA
testing twin movie ever and then he
hopped on a plane apparently he's back
in rehab already but there will be
charges apparently filed against him for
beating himself up how great is that
that is amazing the only way the story
gets better is if the fake Trace Adkins
also checks into rehab the same one then
they're in the same room if there's not
a song that comes out of this for Trace
Adkins next album I don't know what's
gonna it's a perfect country song it
also smack kick the [ __ ] out of myself
cuz I was [ __ ] drunk I hate you cuz
you're me here we go
[Music]
you
[Music]